THE STATE OF NINTENDO:
Nintento is likely the
most classic and well known game company in the
entire world. They’ve made nostalgic fun games
that have captivated hundreds of millions of
people across multiple generations. The Switch
alone has sold well over a hundred million
units, and they’ve even had a movie come
out about one of their biggest IPs: Mario. But,
behind all these layers, the sad reality is that
Nintento has actually been undergoing a massive
recession. Now, it’s not like they’re about to go
bankrupt or something but they have been losing
ground for over 15 years now. Way back in 2009,
for example, Nintendo was pulling in over
$17 billion in revenue. Over the next decade,
this would drop nearly 80% all the way down to
$3.6 billion. Since then, they have been staging
a pretty strong recovery with the Switch and
their mobile games, but even with that, Nintendo
has only been able recover to a little over $10
billion in revenue and that’s not even accounting
for inflation. If we throw inflation into the mix,
we’ll see that Nintendo is only pulling in about
half of what they were back in 2009. And that’s
just the revenue side of things. If we look at the
stock side of things, we’ll see that Nintendo is
struggling to surpass their 2007 high and again,
that’s not even accounting for inflation. And
what’s worse is that to make the Switch work,
Nintendo had to basically cannablize
their entire business and bet it all. So,
now they’re less diversified and more volatile
than ever. And this becomes especially dangerous
given that we’re approaching the end of the
Switch’s lifecycle with it already being
out for nearly 7 years. Given that the Switch is
still selling quite well, it seems that Nintendo
is willing to keep it around for an extra year
or two. But sooner or later, Nintendo will have
release a new console which as we’ve seen in the
past is often hit or miss. So, join me as we take
a closer look at what happened to Nintendo and
their struggle to recapture their former glory.
THE FALL BEGINS:
Taking a look back,
we can’t talk about the legacy and success of
Nintendo without mentioning the NES and SNES.
Compared to modern console sales, these systems
didn’t actually sell all that well coming at 61
million units and 49 million units respectively.
But, their impact on the gaming industry was much
larger than just these numbers. These consoles
are what really put Nintendo on the global map,
introducing franchises like Mario and Zelda to
the entire world. Nintendo had a much different
approach back then as well. It was all about
pushing the boundaries in terms of power,
performance, and innovation. The Nintendo 64, for
example, basically redefined the entire gaming
industry with its revolutionary experimentation
with 3D graphics. Fun fact, Nintendo was even
experimenting with VR way back in 1995 with the
launch of the Nintendo Virtual Boy. And all of
that was just the console side of Nintendo.
Nintendo was also making substantial progress
on the handheld side of things with the Gameboy
and later the DS. But, moving into the 2000s,
Nintendo would flip all of this on its head.
Instead of continuing to push the boundaries
with performance and graphics, Nintendo would
decide to experiment with their first gimmick:
motion controls. It turns out that motion controls
are actually an extremely heated topic and much
of the core gaming community hates then with a
passion, and when you hear them out, it’s not
surprising why. For starters, motion controls
are inherently less reliable than buttons,
and this makes a big difference when it comes to
more intense games. And second of all, people play
video games to relax and chill out, not stand up
and move all over the place. But while the Wii and
it’s motion controls didn’t appeal to hardcore
gamers per se, you know who it did appeal to?
Basically everyone else and I don’t mean that in
a metaphorical sense. This is probably the only
console in history that grandparents bought
not as a Christmas present but as a console
for themselves. The idea was that games like Wii
Fit and Dance Dance Revolution were a fun way to
stay fit and active for any age group. And as
for younger kids, well, being able to swing a
Wii remote as a golf club or a baseball bat or a
tennis racket was a lot cooler than just pressing
buttons. And all of this led to the Wii becoming
Nintendo’s best selling home console of all time
selling just over 100 million units. Motion
controls weren’t the only gimmick that Nintendo
was experimenting with though. After producing
single screen handheld devices for over a decade,
for some reason, Nintendo would decide to make the
DS a dual screen system. This functionality was
basically never useful in any game but that didn’t
really matter because it gave the DS a cool factor
that helped it become the most successful handheld
of all time, selling over 150 million units. This
concurrent explosion of the Wii and DS made the
late 2000s a magical time period for Nintendo but
it also led to a rather faulty line of reasoning.
The idea that Nintendo needed some sort of gimmick
to maximize sales and reach as many people as
possible. The reality was that this was never
what made Nintendo successful in the first place,
but nonetheless, Nintendo would end up doubling
down on gimmicks and they would find out the
hard way that this wouldn’t always end well.
GIMMICKS FALL FLAT:
Nintendo’s next big gimmick was of course 3D with
the 3DS. Around the time that the 3DS launched, 3D
TVs were gaining a bunch of steam due to Avatar.
Avatar had shown that 3D could be done a tasteful
cinematic way that enhanced the user experience,
and given that Avatar would go on to be the
biggest box office hit of all time, it’s no
wonder why TV makers and eventually Nintendo also
wanted a piece of the pie. But as you would guess,
their implementation of 3D was nothing like
Avatar’s implementation. Nintendo’s implementation
of 3D wasn’t an artistic choice, it was an eye
catching feature to sell consoles which it did
somewhat do. The 3DS only sold about half as well
as the DS but that still added up to a solid 75
million units. The same, however, could not be
said about the Wii U. The Wii U’s gimmick was that
you could play console games on a handheld device.
The catch was that you could only be like 15 feet
away from the console so it wasn’t actually all
that useful, but then again, that never stopped
the DS, Wii, or 3DS. Something that did stop the
Wii U though was terrible marketing. For starters,
they decided to name the console the Wii U and
the design looked almost identical to a Wii,
atleast to the average person. The main controller
that you were supposed to use to control the Wii U
other than the GamePad was also just regular old
Wii remotes. So, it was natural that many people
thought that the Wii U was just a pro version of
the Wii as opposed to a next gen console, leading
to really poor sales amongst casual buyers. As for
the core gaming community, these guys knew that
the Wii U was a new console but it didn’t appeal
them all that much. Again, it seemed like Nintendo
was just putting all of their eggs in the gimmick
basket instead of really pushing forward the
industry in terms of perfomance. So, much of the
core gaming audience preferred to just get an Xbox
One or a PS4. And all of this was only made worse
by positive feedback loops. You see, the better
a console sells, the more game developers that
get on board, and the more games that come out,
the better the console sells. However, this works
the other way too. The worse a console sells,
the fewer game developers that get on board,
and the fewer games that come out, the worse
the console sells eventually leading to a deep
dark abyss in terms of sales which is precisely
what happened to the Wii U. The Wii U would end up
being Nintendo’s worst selling console of all time
only selling 13.5 million units. For perspective,
that’s only about an 1/8th of the Wii. Honestly,
this was quite a shame because despite the Wii
U’s flaws and shortcomings, it was actually a
super underrated console with a bunch of solid
first party games like Super Mario 3D World,
Mario Kart 8, and Splatoon. In fact, a lot of
these games would just get ported to the Switch
and end up selling really well. So, the Wii U
definitely had a some hidden gems but in terms
of sales and financials, it was nothing but a
failure. And given that the 3DS and 2DS were also
starting to wind down in terms sales, Nintendo
needed a new hero product: enter the Switch.
BETTING IT ALL:
By the late 2010s, Nintendo’s financials were
looking more depressing than ever with revenue
being down nearly 80%. And that’s why in 2017,
Nintendo would make an unprecedented move. The
move to combine their waning handheld business
with their waning console business. The idea was
obviously that these businesses might be able to
accomplish more together but it also meant that
Nintendo was risking it all on just one console:
the Switch. To be honest, the Switch didn’t solve
any fundamental issue with the Wii U. Being a
hybrid console, it was not even comparable to the
Playstation or Xbox in terms of performance. And
Nintendo was still very much betting on a gimmick
to sell the Switch. The gimmick that you could
take the Switch on the go. In that sense, the
Switch was really just a better version of the
Wii U. It even had a bunch of the same games but
where the Switch really made a difference was
marketing. The name of the console itself was
indicative of what the console was all about.
It was about switching between handheld mode and
console mode. The Switch also had new controllers,
a new console design, and a brand new generation
of kids to market to. And it turns out that this
face lift is all the Wii U needed in order to
go from being Nintendo’s worst selling console
to being almost their best selling console. The
Switch currently stands at a 132 million units
sold meaning that they may even be able to take
the crown for the best selling console of all
time, but that title is rather misleading because
the Switch isn’t directly comparable to any other
console on that list because it’s a handheld and
a console. The Wii and the DS sold a combined 255
million units, so from that perspective, the
Switch is only doing about half as well and
that’s why Nintendo’s financials are also only
doing half as well. They basically cashed in on
both their handheld audience and their console
audience to make the Switch a success. Maybe
that’s not such a bad thing though. Thanks to
the rise of smartphones, selling a separate
handheld gaming device is harder than ever. So,
combining handheld and console and developing
games separately for smartphones may have actually
been a good long term move from Nintendo. Speaking
of mobile games, while Nintendo’s mobile games
are extremely popular clocking in at 738 million
total downloads, it seems that their mobile
revenue has been on a decline for 4 years now,
not even benefitting from pandemic. And given
that Nintendo themselves have admitted that
their mobile games aren’t meant to be massive
revenue drivers, it doesn’t seem like mobile
gaming is the new era Nintendo either. All of
this makes it very unlikely that Nintendo will
ever revisit that peak that they set way back
in the late 2000s, but maybe that’s not such a
bad thing. While revenue isn’t doing better than
ever, Nintendo has figured out how to make similar
levels of profit by doubling their margins from
17% to 35%. So while they may not be as ubiquitous
as they once were, they are as profitable as
they once were. Whether this success continues
on into the future is of course very dependent
on how their next console performs. But seeing
Nintendo experiment with new avenues like mobile
gaming and even movies, it seems that Nintendo
is open to adapting and evolving but only time
will tell. With historically high interest rates,
the appeal bills and bonds is the higher than
ever, yet traditional brokerages haven’t really
adapted with the times. They still expect people
to use clunky bond tables, scroll through long
overwhleming lists, and even use virtual keyboards
till recently. And that’s why we created our own
modern bond platform: Silo. At Silo, we prioritize
the user experience and the ease of finding and
investing in the issuers you know and trust,
so that you too can lock in high yields. Also,
choosing a strong user experience doesn’t mean
sacrificing on safety. Every Silo account is
insured by $500,000 in SIPC insurance and $2.5
million in FDIC insurance. Also, all funds
deposited on the platform will be maintained
by our trusted custodian, Interactive Brokers,
who has experience managing $373 billion
worth of assets over the past 45 years. So,
if you’re looking for a modern way to invest
in bonds, please consider checking out Silo
in the description below. Someone else whos
stuck in a similar situation to Nintendo is
Sony who is now largely dependent on the
PS5. Check out this video to learn more.